okay so the topic of this video is the
genetics inheritance pattern known as
sex-linked inheritance so let's get
started well here's our fictional
henderson family and in my class a few
days ago we met Joshua little baby
Joshua who was diagnosed with PKU which
is an autosomal recessive disorder then
we met Maria's side of the family and we
met Luria's Maria's siblings Lucas and
Martin and their dad Kevin and Mia and
we learned sadly that Kevin and Lucas
have been diagnosed with Huntington's
disease which is an autosomal dominant
disorder now we're going to expand the
family even further there's a baby in
the oven Martin and Andrea are newlyweds
so there's Martin and let's meet Andrea
they're newlyweds so they've just been
married and Andrea Ezra has recently
taken a pregnancy test and discovered
that she is pregnant now when you don't
know the gender of the baby you tend to
just kind of do this diamond symbol
maybe it's a boy maybe it's a girl but
she is worried that her baby might
actually inherit a disorder known as
haemophilia and she's worried because
her father
Andrea's father is a hemophiliac he
suffers from the disorder hemophilia and
she herself is a carrier of the disorder
haemophilia so let's talk about this
disorder
when it comes to sex determination
here's our doctor and gender a person's
gender is determined by genes that are
found on the X and the y chromosome here
is a karyotype notice how this is a
karyotype showing the xx chromosome
combination and women will produce an
egg cell when they're mature sexually
mature and able to have children they'll
produce an egg cell with either with
with a X chromosome in that egg cell and
so women will always pass along an X
chromosome to their children well here's
a karyotype showing an XY chromosome
this is a male karyotype now when it
comes to males and when males are old
enough to produce sperm cells males will
produce half-and-half about half of the
sperm cells produced by a male will
contain an X chromosome and the other
half will contain a Y chromosome and so
men sometimes pass along their X
chromosome and when they do they'll
produce a daughter but when they pass
along their Y chromosome that's how they
produce a son
and we can say that there is a 50/50
chance of a child being born a boy or
girl and we can prove that in this
punnett square if we let's do a Punnett
square to help determine the gender of
children here is the xx chromosome
combination for a woman here is the X Y
chromosome combination for a man when we
fill in this punnett square you can see
that the odds really do come down to
50/50 odds there is a 50% chance that
the child will be born with the xx
chromosome combination and therefore be
a girl and there was a 50% chance
they'll be born with the XY chromosome
combination and therefore be a boy well
let's come to our story here our doctor
is meet meeting with Martin and Andrea
because she's concerned about their
unborn child having the disorder
haemophilia and she says you know my dad
as a hemophiliac so let's add her mom
and dad to this story if he's a
hemophiliac I'm gonna call her in his
square and she says she's a carrier so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna partially
color in her circle to imply that she is
a carrier she's heterozygous and the
doctor says you know Pima philia is a
sex-linked disorder let's catch Martin
up on the genetics clearly Andrea
already understands the genetics but
Martin's probably a little unsure of
what this means
so here's our karyotype and recall that
chromosomes 1 through 22 these are the
autosomes these are chromosomes that do
not possess genes on them to influence
one's gender PKU Huntington's disease
these are examples of autosomal
disorders and if you're in my class
we've already learned these disorders
but what we're learning today focuses on
the sex chromosomes the gene that causes
haemophilia
is located on the X chromosome and
that's why we call him a feely an
example of a sexcellent disorder it's
linked to one of the sex chromosomes and
so that's what a sex linked disorder is
it's an inherited condition that's found
on one of the sex chromosomes they
usually tend to be recessive and yes
there are some dominant sex linked sex
linked disorder but we're focusing on
the most common examples so they're
usually recessive and you know from my
previous examples that I like to use
letter H capital H for healthy because
healthy is dominant and lowercase H for
the disorder now in this case let's
focus on women first
the xx chromosome combination is the
combination for for a female and when it
comes to the xx chromosome combination
notice I've attached a superscript
capital H onto each of these X
chromosomes this is homozygous dominant
and it would result in a a woman that's
healthy they would not have this these
disorders or a woman can be heterozygous
she can inherit one dominant allele and
one of her x chromosomes and a recessive
allele on her other X chromosome she'd
still be healthy but we'd call her a
carrier and our cartoon story this is
Andrea she said she's a carrier and then
a woman could be it's rare for women to
have these disorders but it can happen
a woman can possess not one
X chromosome with the recessive allele
but - that's the only way women can have
these disorders but in men it's a little
different man you know males have the X
and Y chromosome combination so that
means on the X chromosome if there's a
dominant capital H allele the man will
be healthy and not have the disorder but
if the man's X chromosome has the
recessive allele they will have the
disorder now you might be wondering well
what about the Y chromosome does that
kind of provide any protection and the
answer is no because hemophilia which is
the one we're examining today this is a
disorder found on the X chromosome and
so even though a man has a Y chromosome
the Y chromosome doesn't really offer
any protection or backup or anything and
so men our doctor says men are most
commonly affected by sex linked
disorders because these are usually
found on the X chromosome and they're
rare in women it can happen it's not
completely unheard of but they're these
disorders tend to be rare in women women
have a second X chromosome a backup X
chromosome and so if one of their X
chromosomes has the recessive allele on
it there's a good chance there other X
chromosome will have the dominant
healthy allele and therefore they'll be
healthy there'll be a carrier but they
won't have the disorder now if we look
at this karyotype here and if we zoom on
in the the X and the y chromosome let's
talk about some examples some examples
of what we call x-linked disorder these
are disorders that are located the gene
has been located on the X chromosome one
of them would be colorblindness
colorblindness the gene responsible has
been found on the X chromosome
another example is hemophilia the story
were looking at today the gene response
falls on the X chromosome and there is a
type of muscular dystrophy where the
gene responsible is on the X chromosome
when it comes to what we call y-linked
disorders there are a couple examples
this I found as well I think it's
pronounced Sawyer syndrome I don't know
much too much too much about this
particular syndrome but the gene
responsible is on the y chromosome as is
a type of infertility Y chromosome
infertility the gene responsible is on
the Y chromosome so these would only
affect men because only men males have Y
chromosomes but let's focus just on
hemophilia today since that's kind of
the disorder facing this family so if we
come back to our cartoon family here I
know that Andrea's dad is a male so I
can give him the X Y chromosome
combination I know Andrea's mom is a
woman so I can give her the X X
combination Andrea as a woman so I can
give her the xx chromosome combination
Martin's a man so I can give him the X Y
chromosome combination and our doctor
says you know because your dad actually
has the disease hemophilia his genotype
must be the X with the lowercase H
that's the only possible genotype of a
man that would suffer from these
disorders and so he must have passed on
his X with the lowercase H - Andrea his
daughter we know he didn't pass along
the Y chromosome because Andrea's female
therefore the dad must have passed along
his X chromosome so Andrea received her
dad's X chromosome with the lowercase H
my mother has no history of hemophilia
in her family and so that means when it
comes to Andrea's mom I can label her
genotype this X with capital H for each
of them and so that means that her mom
must have passed along an x with a
capital dominant H and that's why andrea
is healthy she has this backup X
chromosome with the capital H on it so
she's fine she's healthy she does not
have hemophilia but she's a carrier
in Martin since you do not suffer from
haemophilia your genotype must be the
next to the capital H that's the only
possible combination of a male who does
not have this particular disorder so now
that we know Martin and Andrea's
genotype we can set up a punnett square
for them there is a genotype of Martin
there's the genotype of Andrea and when
we fill in this punnett square not only
can we tell if they're gonna be healthy
or have a disorder but we can also
identify their gender X X chromosome
combination is a female and because
there's capital H's we know that that
female will be healthy X X chromosome
combination is a female and a capital H
with a lowercase H means that the person
will be healthier but healthy but a
carrier now here's the X Y chromosome
combination but there's a capital H
there so I know it's gonna be a male
who's healthy and here's the X and Y
chromosome combination but there's a
lowercase H so the hair is a boy who
would suffer from the disorder
hemophilia and so our doctor says you
can see there is a 25% chance that you
that you could have a child with
haemophilia
one square out of four and if the child
is a boy we don't know yet but if the
child is a boy there was a 50/50 chance
that he will suffer from hemophilia and
if the child is a girl there was a 50/50
chance that she will be a carrier the
good news is if it's a girl the child
will be healthy regardless however the
child could be a carrier and Andrea says
you know I think we'd like to know the
gender of the baby well that's kind of
the end of this cartoon family here but
before we're done I want to do some some
summary review here so here's a practice
problem if you're if you're watching you
know pause the video read through that
sentence right there and then try to
answer these four questions I'm gonna go
over the answer in three
- one okay the story says Jen is a
healthy carrier of this disorder
hemophilia and Adam has no history in
his family so when I fill in the punnett
square I can see there's the option of a
healthy girl I can see there's the
probability probability of a healthy boy
there is a probability of a healthy girl
who's a carrier and there's the
probability of a boy who has hemophilia
so now look at the four questions
question a what is the probability they
have a daughter with hemophilia and the
answer is zero they can produce a male a
son with hemophilia but not a daughter
question beef what are the chances they
can produce a carrier child the answers
one square out of four 25% what is the
chance they could produce a child with
hemophilia the answer is one square out
of four 25% and that child will be a boy
if they have hemophilia what is the odds
of producing two healthy children now
this question is a little trickier you
might think the answer is 75% three
squares out of four but that's not the
right answer
the answer is 9/16 or 56% well how did I
get that answer let's explain here's two
babies pretend they have baby one in the
Year 2015 and pretend to have baby 2 in
the year 2018 or pretend it's 2015 right
now what are the odds that the baby born
in 2015 will be healthy look at the
punnett square there is a 3 out of 4
chance that the baby in 2015 will be
healthy couple years go by it's now 2018
then an atom one have a second child
what is the ads that the child born in
2018 is healthy look at the punnett
square there is a 3 out of 4 chance that
the baby in 2018 is healthy so how come
the answer is not 3/4 because I have to
combine the odds of the two babies I do
that by multiplying together what's 3
times 3 in the numerator it's 9 what's 4
times 4 in the denominator
it's 16 that's why the answer is 9/16
here's another practice problem
haemophilia is a sex-linked disorder
pause the video and try to answer these
questions and try to draw the pedigree
I'm gonna go through the answers in 3 2
1
okay so there's Kelly I think Kelly
implies a circle she does not have
hemophilia even though her mother did
her mother had the disorder which is
rare for women to have these disorders
but it's not impossible it can happen
notice how I colored in Kelly's mother
coloring the symbols whenever they have
the disorder and there was Jim he is a
hemophiliac
so I colored in Jim Square their first
child a child's name is Barry I think
that implies male and he's healthy but
their other child Rachel Rachel implies
a girl she's a hemophiliac
so I colored in her circle and it's not
impossible for women to have sex with
disorders like this it's just it's just
uncommon and the question says draw a
pedigree there there's the pedigree and
now let's do a Punnett square well I can
start time before I do the punnett
square let me identify the genotypes
well if Kelly's mom has disease there's
her genotype that's the only combination
of a woman who has a disease that's the
genotype of Jim that's the only
combination that would produce a man
with the disorder well there's Rachel
she must be homozygous recessive because
that's the only way to produce a female
with the disorder well there's Barry the
Barry Barry I know is healthy from the
story the story says Barry is healthy
that's the only possible combination
that will produce a man that's healthy
now look at Kelly I know she has an X
chromosome with the lowercase H she must
have received that from her mother
now the story doesn't really tell me
anything about her father but I know she
had to receive an X chromosome from her
dad
so clearly if I can draw a square to
symbolize her dad right here I know that
Kelly does not have hemophilia it says
that in the story
so therefore the dad must be fine
Kelly's dad must not have hemophilia he
must have passed his X with the capital
H now I can draw a Punnett Square for
Jim and Kelly
there's Jim's genotype and there's
Kelly's genotype when I fill in the
punnett square
I can see these results right here now I
look at the four questions what is the
probability of having a healthy son the
answer is one square out of four 25%
question B what's the chance of having a
healthy daughter the answer is one
square out of four 25% question C what
is the odds are the probability of
having a child with hemophilia the
answer is two squares out of four or 50%
and question D or did the chances of
having a child who's a carrier you can
see it's one square out of four and so
there you have a practice problem now
this right here is a real good challenge
here's a pedigree involving 14 people
pause the video try to identify the
genotype of these 14 people there's a
hint one person in this family you're
not going to be able to uh to determine
their genotype so here we go let's go
ahead and pause the video when you're
done let's check our answers I'm gonna
go over the answer in three two one
I think the easiest way to start is with
the squares the male's because there's
only two possible genotypes if the if
the symbol if the square is colored in
like person five thirteen and fourteen
then they have to have the X with the
lowercase H and because they're males I
can add the Y chromosome now I know that
the other squares person one three seven
10 and 11 they're squares so they're
males they have the app-v have to have
the X and Y chromosome combination and
because the squares are not colored in
they're not shaded they have to be
healthy which means they have B capital
H on the X chromosome so I've already
finished a good number of people in this
pedigree so now I want to turn my
attention to the circles the females
there's three possible genotypes for the
circles the women but I can cross out
the bottom one because none of the
circles are shaded in gray there none of
them are colored in so none of the
circles have the disorder but I have to
figure out are the circles homozygous
dominant or heterozygous and that's
where the challenge comes in well every
symbol that's left all the circles are
our women's and and they're not colored
in so they're healthy women so because
they're healthy women I can go ahead and
give them an X with a capital H I know
they have at least one X with a capital
H I'm trying to figure out what's their
other X chromosome does it have a
capital H or a lowercase H well child 5
is gonna be a big help boy 5 he's a boy
so he must have received the Y
chromosome from his dad if he got the Y
chromosome from the dad then that X
chromosome that he has must have come
from his mom and so notice that child 5
allows me to figure out that woman
number 2 is a heterozygous carrier so I
can go ahead and color in half of her
circle and we can use that same logic to
help us uncover another woman look at
boy 13
he's a boy boy 13 got the Y chromosome
from his father
which means boy 13 got the X chromosome
from his mother so we now know that
woman 6 also has to be a carrier
well we can go ahead and use that same
logic to to solve another woman look at
boy 14 boy 14 is a boy he got his Y
chromosome from his dad
which means boy 14 got his X chromosome
from his mom so I now know woman number
nine has to be a heterozygous carrier
now let's try to figure out the other
circles remember the hint that I gave
you is that one person is unknown and we
don't know person four and 12 yet but we
can figure out one of the two first of
all look at woman number nine I know she
got the X chromosome from her dad that's
why she's a woman so she received an X
with a capital H from her father
so where did whoa a woman 9 look at
woman 9 where did her X with the
lowercase H come from that had to come
from the mom and so I now know that
woman 4 has to have an X with a
lowercase H she has to be a carrier now
my dilemma now is woman 12 I know she's
gonna she's gonna receive an X with the
capital H from her dad that I know
she's gonna get an X with the capital H
from the dead the problem with woman 12
is what does she get from the mom I
don't know there's a 50% chance that she
receives an X with a capital H from her
mom there's a 50% chance that she
receives an X with the lowercase H from
her mom so that's the one person whose
genotype we just don't know and there
you go if you're in my class you know
pause this quiet
pause the video and try to answer these
five questions I'm happy to check your
answers before a school or after school
one day hope you found this video
helpful thanks for watching